Noël est une fête magique. Pleine de merveilles, d'amusements et de joie.
Un moment pour créer des souvenirs inoubliable avec la famille et les amis.
Connais tu le secret caché, celui qui fait que noël est si spécial.
LES MAMANS
Les mamans travaillent comme des dingues...
cuisinant, emballant, décorant et faisant les courses
Je penses pas pouvoir faire ça sobre.
Les filles, envie de vous souler à la cafet?
Oh, oui!
J'ai l'impression d'être une gigantesque boule de stress de Novembre jusqu'au Nouvel an.
Je passe des mois à choisir le cadeau parfait pour tout le monde.
Vous savez ce que j'ai en retour?
Des coupons pour des massages du dos gratuits.
C'est pas possible!
De mauvais massages!
Vous vous rappelez quand les vacances étaient plutôt fun?
Récupérons Noël.
Maman?
Maman?!
Hey, maman!
Mais où est ton sapin?
Je n'ai pas envie de passer mon Noël à faire les courses. J'ai juste envie de profiter de Noël cette année.
T'es une maman.
Les mamans ne profite pas mais font profiter. C'est ça, être une maman.
Aaah la maison est vraiment cool.
Oooh Merci!
Ton père est génial.
Je pensais que tu le détestais...
Attend, Quoi?! Pourquoi tu dis ça?
Je vous ai entendu toi et papa dans la chambre. T'arrêtais pas de lui crier dessus.
C'était juste... c'était des cris de joie
Et après tu as tapé le mur et crié des insultes
Ton père est moi étions en train de jouer à un petit jeu d'adulte
Vous avez joué à ce jeu 7 fois..
Six et demi..